[MUSIC]
You all are in an absolutely
wonderful place in your career.
I know it's hard work and
you struggle to get in here and
probably times you wonder whether this
whole experience was was worth it,
cost you time and money to come here.
But I think when you look back
on this experience at Stanford,
the connections that you made,
the classmates that you met, and
the things that you learn while you were
here, I think you will absolutely find
that this was well worth the sacrifice
to come here and complete the program.
Having said that.
[COUGH] It also puts you
in a very unique place and
it's why I choose to take
the tack I do with these remarks.
Because contrary to most other times in
your career, you were at an ideal point.
If you choose to do it to
kind of hit the reset button
on your career, MBA or
a mid career masters,
any other graduate degree that
has a break from your work.
And as you come out different
than when you went in gives
you this opportunity to hit the reset
button and do something different.
Now there are some
limitations on how far afield
from where you've been
that you can easily go.
You can do, you can go a little
more afield with more and more and
more difficulty,
nothing is impossible, especially for
Stanford graduates, as we all know.
But one of the things I want to try
to touch on here today a little
bit is what's easy, and what's hard.
And then you can choose, where in that
spectrum of things that that you want to
position yourself, and maybe we'll have
some tips in terms of how to do it.
And in the q&a, fire away,
I always get some interesting questions.
I'll do the best I can to be dead honest
with you because the last thing you
need from anybody like me is
some platitudes about how easy
something is going to be when it's hard.
Or how something that you think you
want to do is going to work and
are probably won't work.
And if that's the case,
I'm just going to tell you that and
you can value the advice
that what it cost you.
To get started, I thought I would
go through about a dozen slides.
This will be real quick but
there's some things in here that I
hope get you thinking a little bit.
And maybe cause a question or
two that we can deal with later.
Because I really want the bulk of the time
here to be devoted to your questions.
And my experience has been your questions,
generate other questions, and
the audience starts to play off each
other and we have a little fun.
But let me run through this fairly quickly
if you have a question about the slides,
feel free to interrupt me.
This is really informal and we're going to
have to hold everything until the end.
But I'd like to try to set the stage
a little bit with just some initial
thoughts that I call launching or
relaunching an executive career.
And there we go.
So here's a here's a pretty
obvious statement.
And we'll start with an easy when
companies are formed and built and
grown on three legs of a three legged
stool, ideas, money and talent.
Those are the three things
that's all there is.
So what about these three things, ideas.
Ideas are never in short supply.
As I said there's almost an infinite
number of ideas for product service and
technology in the world.
And every time somebody makes a stupid
statement that everything important in
this field is invented virtually.
The next day somebody comes up and
proves them wrong with a new idea and
has everybody said yeah I never
thought of that I wish I had money.
You need money to build businesses, but
money is normally in
pretty adequate supply.
In every business cycle,
good ideas get funded.
And in some of them, as we've seen over
and over again, lousy ideas get funded.
But good ideas can always
find funding somewhere.
So what's the shortage?
Shortage is you.
The shortage is talent.
It's in limited supply.
It's finite.
At the leadership level it's not
only finite, it's declining.
As baby boomers who have been
the leadership core of the world for
the last 20 years, my generation.
Getting out of these jobs and doing
things like this talking to people like
you who were taken over for
my generation, and you can't make more.
There's only that many people
of that age and that talent.
And so, what that says is this leadership
shortage which is going to be forever
Is really good news for you.
If you have a compelling story,
and if you tell your story,
the right way to the right people,
then no matter how good your story is,
if you don't tell it to
anybody that can help you.
And if you have a lousy story and
you tell it to the wrong people,
that's not going to get
you anywhere anyway.
So what about resumes?
I'm asked a lot of times about resumes,
and
I probably pay less attention
to resumes than most people do.
You got to have one maybe,
I mean, frankly today,
your LinkedIn profile
may be good enough for
most of the things that you've got to do.
If you don't have a LinkedIn profile,
you got to get one and do that.
Do that quick,
make sure it's always current, and
make sure it's always accurate.
Beyond a resume this is a document
that helps you tell your story.
And it'll help you if you have a good
story to tell and if you tell it right.
So what makes a good story?
Well, in my opinion, good choices,
because you're going to have to be
explaining them with logical explanations.
Because in your career, you're going to be
faced with a number of times where you're
going to be sitting down across the table.
From somebody that you want to convince,
they ought to do something positive for
you.
And they're probably,
going to look at your background and
look at your resume and start asking you
questions like, well, why did you do that?
Why did you make that choice?
Why did you go here instead of there?
Why didn't you stay and
get promoted in this job?
If in fact you were doing as
good as you tell me, you were.
Company and people over product and
compensation,
I generally advise people to go work for
the best people they can work for.
And for
the best companies they can work for.
If the products not right and
it's a good company and you're working for
great people that'll get fixed over time.
If it's a greatest product in the world
and you're working for lousy people,
they'll find a way to mess it up and
you'll be on the outs.
Venture capitalists
understand this all too well.
I mean, one of the oldest sayings
in the venture capital world
is A management team with a B product will
find a way to make their investors money.
And a B management team with an A product
will find a way to mess it up.
I mean, and that's how they invest.
You look at their record, and
you'll see it it's people.
Measurable accomplishments and promotions.
If you can focus on anything when
you're putting your story together.
Focus on what you have accomplished that
you can legitimately take credit for,
or at least partial credit for.
And be clear which is which
when you're explaining it,
that's measurable with facts and figures
and things that people will recognize and
ideally which got you promoted.
Credible transitions and moves as I said,
you're going to be explaining your moves.
Over time to people who are not
going to take bullshit or
fluffy answers and
pay much attention to them.
So think about that before you
make a transition or a move and
certainly as you're making it,
how you're going to be explaining it 10,
15, 20 years down the road.
Recognized mentors and references.
As you're building a career,
you're going to work for people and
whether you like it or not the reputation
of those people rubs off on you.
If it's good, it helps you.
If it's bad, it hurts you.
And there's not a whole lot that you can
do about that other than to be smart in
your choices.
And if you find that you're working for
somebody whose reputation
is likely to hurt you because
their reputation is bad, get out.
Get away or get out and
do it as fast as you can.
And finally, what makes a good story
when you're telling it to somebody.
Is at the end of the day at the end of
the conversation, you've gotta be able to
convince them that you can be successful
doing something that in fact,
they want done.
Because if you can convince
them that you can do it, but
it isn't anything that they need to
have done, then you won't go anywhere.
Or if they have something that
they need to have done and
you can't convince them
that you can do it.
It doesn't go anywhere.
It's only when you put
those two things together,
that telling your story to
somebody that matters and
can do something positive with
it will get you a good outcome.
How do you tell it?
Well,
we've touched on some of this clear
clarity of goals and accomplishments.
I'm basically an advocate of a simple
chronological resume that says
what you did, when you did it, who you
did it for what the results were and, and
what happened to you as a result.
I mean, if you think about those things,
that's what I'm always looking for.
I don't like a lot of fluffy explanations
of, things that don't matter.
Facts are good if they're true.
Promotions are better.
Accurate facts and dates,
easy to pick out successes.
Keep in mind that you want somebody who's
looking at your resume, or looking at
your LinkedIn profile to look at something
on there and say, I can use that.
That fits here, that's interesting.
Logical transitions,
no misrepresentations or vague claims.
And a clear and
credible path to what you seek.
We'll come back to that because
that last points important and
we're going to cover that in the Q&A.
Because doesn't matter how good your
background is in a conversation that
you're having with somebody about
the potential of working for him.
Unless you can convince them
that excellent background
fit something that they need to have done.
Otherwise, it's a nice conversation.
They probably like you and say, you've
got a great background that fit here.
But, why are you telling
me your story you should
be telling it to somebody who
can do something about it.
We talk a lot about networks.
Most people don't have any idea how big
their networks in fact, really are.
Your networks are enormous.
I mean,
you start with the people in the room.
You start with everybody they know.
You start with people that they know.
You look at graduates of Stanford,
people that they know,
the places that they've worked.
Before you know it,
you can define your network,
literally as being hundreds
of thousands of people.
Because anybody who can make a connection
to somebody that might be willing
to help you,
is in fact part of your network.
And you may not even know who they are.
But they're part of your network and
you can make that work for you.
If you want to meet somebody, usually
somebody in the Stanford Business school
alumni, committee will
make an introduction for
you if you can figure out
the right way to get to them.
And the right way to ask that question.
GSB alums will usually help.
I'll make this point because
I always make it and
that is almost anybody is
going to be willing to help you.
I'd be willing to help you.
Your classmates would be willing
to help you, your professors.
Alumni will be willing to help you, but
very few of them are going to be
willing to do your homework for you.
And so an example, if you call me and
say, Tom, I want to get into,
venture capital.
Would you introduce me to
some venture capitalists?
What, that's a lazy question, okay?
But if you said I've got two years
in the venture capital industry and
I worked on a project that's
Josh Green and Ward David L.
Is a board member of I know you know,
Josh,
because I know you work
with him on a board.
Would you be willing to
introduce me to Josh Green so
that I can have a conversation about this
project that I know he's interested in.
Okay, that now, that night and
day those two questions the first one
general requires work on my part.
And I'm not going to go do
a lot of work to try to figure
out what you could have figured out and
didn't.
But the second one, if I believe that
that's a very credible question,
it takes me about 30 seconds to pop
off an email to Josh and say, Look,
this is somebody I think
you ought to meet.
They've specifically picked
you out of the hundreds or
thousands of venture capital people.
Because of your experience in this company
and they're interested in that and
they think they had some dad would you
meet with them for, 15 to 20 minutes.
Specific on the one hand,
general on the other hand,
they said pick specific targets
make specific requests.
And then if somebody does you a favor,
particularly somebody that didn't have any
reason to do it other than they
were just trying to help you.
After the thing is done,
you met with Joshua Hunter, go back,
send them an email and
tell them what happened.
Hey, I met with Josh,
thanks for setting that up.
I'm not sure what's going to come out
of it, but I really appreciate it.
We're going to stay in touch.
Thank you.
Believe me, that will pay dividends later.
First of all, it's just good common
courtesy if somebody did something for
you that they didn't have to do to
call them up and thank them and
tell them what happened.
Because they're probably curious.
It also leaves that door open to go
back to them again in the future because
they've got a good feeling about you.
This is somebody that
handled that right and
it'd be willing to go do another
favour for you down the road.
Whereas, I've got a lot of people I won't
name them maybe I will later a few but
who seems like every couple
of years would call me up and
say, Tom, it's been so
long since we've talked.
I really wanted to get back to you and
see how you were doing.
Well, I'm doing fine.
[LAUGH] How are you doing?
Well, I you know, I'm getting work out.
I was looking for a job.
Well what happened with the last
thing that you called me about two
years ago that you never came back and
told me what happened about that.
And, maybe I'll be polite to him,
maybe I want more likely they don't
somehow I'm out of town or
something when that call comes in.
And my EA just handles it,
it never sees the light of day.
Stay connected to the people
who have helped you.
And my career was the executive search
business, I started very early.
I think it was like 32, I spent 30
years with Hedrick and struggles.
We were the largest search from the world
for a long time, I think pretty
much the most respected senior executive
search firm in the world then and now.
I did a lot of things with the firm
including spending the last five years
before I retired from that as,
as chairman and CEO.
We were a public company by then with
70 offices in 40 countries and 500 and
some partners spread
out all over the place.
And, It's amazing to me that so
many people who interact with
executive search firms Don't have hardly
any clue about how the profession works,
and what it does, and what it doesn't do,
and how it can work for you.
Let me give you an example.
There's thousands of
search firm partners and
my firm had about 500,
they were spread out all over the world.
But for any one particular thing,
particularly at the very senior
level where recruiters in every firm begin
to specialize on industry and function.
For somebody in this audience, there
might have been in my firm 3, 4, maybe 5
of the 500 recruiters that it would be
useful to build a relationship with.
And 495 who might like you,
might be friends, might be a neighbor,
might help you in a different way,
I'll come back to that, but
would never be in a position to have an
assignment where you could be a candidate.
Because maybe you're consumer
products chief marketing officer,
and your next door neighbor is a partner
in one of the big five executive
recruiting firms, and does chief
information officer searches for
industrial companies, pretty much only and
dominates that space.
There is zero chance that that person
will ever have a direct assignment that
you can be a candidate for.
But that person knows those five
people who are the five people in that
firm that you ought to get to know.
And the way to use them if you can get
a relationship with them is tell them
exactly either what kind of person or if
you can do your research, it's usually not
very hard, what specific person in their
firm you'd like to get introduced to.
And they'll probably do that for
you because it's the stock in trade.
Recruiters work for clients,
we work exclusively for clients,
but we have this kind of odd
three-party symbiotic relationship.
It's completely unique in professional
service representation where
we get paid by one side of a transaction,
but have to be perceived as fair,
balanced, and
delivering value to both sides.
Lawyers don't get that.
I mean, you got two companies
fighting with each other,
company a has got a lawyer,
company b has got a lawyer.
The lawyers fight with each other, but
they know who they're representing.
They're not trying to be fair,
they're advocates.
They're advocates for their side.
Marketing people, PR people,
accountants, they're working for
their clients and
every client has one of those.
But the search profession is pretty odd,
so the people that do it have to tread
this line between loyalty to a client and
respect and loyalty among the candidates.
because unless that they can put
a transaction together with two willing
parties who are both smart and
ideally not going to do something that's
not in the both of their best interests.
No transaction happens, no search gets
completed, and nothing gets done,
and that person doesn't stay
in the business very long.
So you can make that work for
you as long as you understand that
it's not the recruiter's job to
find you your next position.
It's the recruiter's job to solve
the problem that their client has.
And if you can be the solution to that
problem, then they're going to be real
happy to bring you forward and
have you be a candidate for that project.
If you're not the solution to that
problem, two things can happen.
If you recognize it early on and raise
your hand and say this isn't right for me,
what I'm really interested in is x.
Let me try to help you with a suggestion
of somebody better than me for
this project.
And would you remember me for something or
introduce me to one of your colleagues
who's working on what I want to do?
That's a good interaction,
that will serve you well.
What won't serve you well is either trying
to convince a recruiter, any recruiter,
really at any level,
that you're something that you're not
because they'll figure it out eventually.
Or that you are interested in something
that in the end you're really not
interested in because you're
wasting the recruiter's time which
is the only asset they have
to make a living with,
and they don't appreciate it
when their time's wasted.
They know every set of interactions is not
going to lead to a successful outcome.
And you may go all the way to the end and
you may decide or
the client may decide this isn't right,
it didn't happen.
But as long as that was done with good
faith, nobody has any hard feelings.
But if it was done with bad faith, and
bad faith can be on the client side too,
I've experienced this as well.
In which case I apologized
to the candidates and
try to make it right if I can.
But nobody worries about
that as long as everybody
is proceeding along
the path with good faith.
Be specific, be special,
try to be very clear when you're
dealing with recruiters of any kind.
What is it you want?
What you're willing to do?
What you're not willing to do?
And ask the kind of questions to try to
decide if this opportunity that they've
put in front of you or called you about
is the right potential one for you.
If it is, say so.
Don't be cute,
don't play hard to get, be honest,
there would be plenty of time for
negotiation at the end.
If it isn't, pull out fast and
don't waste your time.
Don't lie or embellish your resume.
My colleagues and
I spent years honing skills to
smell bullshit coming a mile away.
I mean, a good recruiter will not let
you get away with claiming something
that isn't true, that's fluffy,
credit for something that really maybe
you had a small part of and
you're trying to take too much credit for.
You don't need to do that,
you've got good records.
Just be honest and
try to position yourself someplace where
your skill set and
your interests fit what the clients needs.
Covered some of this other stuff.
The second one though I
want to come back to because
as you think about what it is that you
want to do, there is a role there for
executive recruiters to play over
a long period in your career.
And the key, I think for all of you, is
to figure out literally that handful and
it's probably no more than that
in any particular geography.
If you go more broadly global,
it could be a little more,
it's still not a big number.
And I doubt for most of you,
the critical mass of recruiters
among the major search firms
who would be in a position to
be really good career-long allies and
sources for you,
I would be very surprised if that was
more than 10 or 12 people in total.
That's a number of people that
you can over time get to know.
It's not hundreds, that's hard, but
10, 6, 8, 10, 12, you can do that.
Particularly, if you identify who they are
and have a strategy to get to know them in
a positive way through introductions
of people, other search people,
others who will help you.
But get to know them in a positive way,
stay connected, don't be a pain in
the neck, but stay connected, and build
a very long-term relationship with them.
Particularly the ones that are working
in your chosen field a level or
two above where you are now.
Because over time, they'll move up too,
and as you move up,
you'll be heading into their
space from below as it will.
And those are the people you
want to be dealing with,
not the ones that are working at or below
your level now, which by the time you get
your next promotion, you've outgrown
them and they can't help you anymore.
So you want to be aiming high.
So what do companies want
when they're hiring people?
Companies in every cycle are hiring
people, they're trying to hire good
people they want to understand what your
career is and how it fits with them.
They're looking for skills and experience
that closely match their needs as they see
them and probably you can't do a whole lot
to convince them to see it some other way.
This third one's really
important because anybody,
even the CEO, hiring somebody has
got to answer to his or her board.
And everybody else has a boss, maybe
more than one boss, and if they're going
to hire you go explain to somebody
else probably somebody you never met.
Maybe you met him but
maybe you didn't, why they want to
hire you as opposed to somebody else.
And it's your job if you want
that job to make it easy for
them to explain to whoever they have
to explain to why it is that they want
to hire you as opposed to anybody
else that they might hire.
So if you put yourself in that mindset and
say, you got to tell a story, not only
will they believe but that they can
retell, because they're going to have to,
they're going to have to justify
this decision to somebody.
And so,
the easier you can make that for them,
the more likely they are to hire you,
which says personality and
style that fits their culture,
every company has has a culture.
Some cultures are more comfortable for
some people than others some companies
are more female friendly than others,
some are more ethnically open than others.
Some are more open to different
nationalities than others you can fight
that We can all deplore that and
say that's horrible, but
you're looking for a job.
And I mean if you if you go back to one
of the things that I've always loved that
my good friend Jim Collins, Jim probably
speaks around here once in a while,
is fond of saying is is look for
the open door.
He said so many people go through their
lives spending an awful lot of energy,
trying to pound their way through
doors that are closed and locked.
It's possible, but
it's hard down the hall, three doors down,
maybe there's an open door with somebody
there that would say, come on in.
Once in a while you may want to think
about maybe I'll go down there and
go through that open door as opposed
to trying to find my way through
this one it's locked or locked to
me now it may be locked to me for
reasons that I find reprehensible.
Yeah, you can decide if you want to
try to change that good luck to you or
you can say, I'll do that in my
spare time, but I need a job so
I want to go someplace where somebody
wants me for what I am for who I am.
And they like what I am as opposed
to me trying to convince them they
should like what I am when they don't
simple as that no side issues or
hassles, the more the easier
you make it to recruit you.
The more likely it is that somebody is
going to do that because this gets back
again to they going to explain this to
somebody else if they want somebody to
start the first of next month, and
you don't want to start for three months,
that's a problem for them, particularly if
they've got another candidate might not be
as good as us willing to
start when they want.
If you need a lot more compensation
than they're prepared to pay or
you have a whole lot of other
complicated things that they have to
deal with that's hard, so,
the point there is think about what it is.
Somebody said the difference between what
you'd like to have and what you need
to have focus on that make it easy to hire
you, compensation demands they can meet.
Sometimes you can push the boundaries
We've got another little
Presentation I do on
negotiating compensation.
I don't think we're going to have
the time to do that tonight, but
if anybody has any questions about that,
we'll handle it in the Q and A.
And once somebody hires you, they want
you to go, they want you to onboard,
you should want that too, but they want
you to onboard starting and engaged
So we're in Silicon Valley, and many of
you either have work in startups in fact,
how many of you have worked in start-ups?
Not too many usually it's more okay,
how many of you are thinking
about working in startups?
Okay, I mean, let me know if I got the
maths, right how many of you have worked
in startups before or thinking about
going back into startups again?
One, two three, okay, good so
you didn't get turned off
by the first time somebody
asked I'm not sure who it was.
It might have been John Doerr at
Kleiner Perkins said, if one time he said,
if you're trying to figure out
if you're an entrepreneur,
you're not which I always
thought was kind of interesting.
If you need structure,
then nothing wrong with that big
companies need a lot of people,
the good places to work, and
if that's you, that's fine go big.
Lots of big companies recruiting here lots
of big companies are great places to work
for entire careers if you decide to go
to a start-up, I would pose not for
everybody but for the people in
this room because you're special.
You're a special group of people
I would say if it's a start-up,
you want to be focused on
a couple of things and I say,
will you be at the table at the table
means are you going to be in the group,
the small group of people
that makes the key decisions.
They're in a closed room with the door
closed when something big is coming down
and bet the company are really
important decisions have to be made.
If you're at that table, doesn't matter
a whole lot what your job title is,
what your compensation is, really are or
any else because it'll all be taken care
of if you're not at the table,
and you're outside.
Looking through the keyhole trying to
figure out what's going on in that room
when the key decisions are being made,
I would say to you if to start up most of
the time, the risk reward ratio for
you is not right.
That puts you in in the world of
four box matrix is in the high risk,
low reward box and
I don't think that's a box that you ought
to be intentionally aiming yourself to.
That if the company is wildly successful,
you make a little bit of money and
you weren't really part of the team
that drove it on the other hand,
if you're in the high risk,
high reward box, yeah, that can be great.
Can you handle the risk?
What do you do if it fails?
Some cultures, some geographies failures
really hard it's really hard to explain or
somebody said once how
are you going to go home and
tell your mother that your company failed.
If you grew up around
Silicon Valley it was okay,
big deal what are you going to do next?
But there's some places in the country and
in the world where that's going
to be really hard for you?
And if it is, and
you don't feel like you're up for it,
maybe that's not where you want to go.
Are the leaders of the startup
professionals or are they friends?
I put up a big red flag every time I see a
startup that's three college roommates and
get together because they
want to start a company.
I'll be the CEO and so you'd be the
marketing VP and what do you want to be
okay, engineering well, we got to have one
okay, well, you're really not very good.
That's a bad way to get
a company started and
if you get into a company where
the officers are friends and
they wouldn't be picked for their talent
in a fair fight against other people.
This has a very high probability of coming
out with the worst possible outcome
you could imagine, which is you lose
the company, you lose the job, and
you probably lose your
friends in the process.
So I just say Massive caveats
on going in any startup where
a bunch of your friends get together and
choose up sides.
Is the financing solid for
at least a year?
Because you don't want to be coming
into something unless there's at
least a year of runway there before
the company needs to raise money,
because maybe it won't, and that's tough.
As I said, if it's a tough choice, say no.
We have like two slides left and
we're going to Q&A.
I know you had do you have a question
you want to ask before you left?
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> [INAUDIBLE] Contrary to somebody,
I recruited CEOs mostly for a living, and
there's a popular wisdom that you really
want to go out when you're looking for
a CEO, and find somebody that's done
this successfully two or three times.
And that's the spiel we gave to our
clients, it was a big part of our sale.
They bought it most of the time,
wasn't true.
The fact of the matter is, most successful
CEOs that you could think about and
that you could identify did the job.
They succeeded the first time they tried
it, most of them never did it again.
A few did, generally with less
success than they did the first time,
but it is very few successful, successive
entrepreneurs of CEOs of multiple things.
I say experience counts, but
the best succeed the first time.
Here's where I say, and
this is contrarian thinking,
and it's contrary into the experience
most of you will have,
or you'll have a lot of jobs, you'll work
for a number of companies in your tenures.
Maybe fairly short, and they're getting
shorter in this day and age, but
I urge you each time that you think about
taking a job, whether it's the one you
get out of here, when you hit that
reset button, or each subsequent time.
I urge you to at least put some of your
effort into the thought process that this
is the last change I'm ever going to make,
and
I'm going to work for this company for
the rest of my working career.
I'm going to run it one day, and
then I'm going to retire from it
having spent my whole career here.
Chances are pretty good it won't happen,
but
that mindset will serve
you well no matter what.
It happened to me, wasn't my first time,
wasn't my second time.
I found something that I really liked,
I stayed with the company for 30 years,
I ran it, I retired from it.
So I admit my bias is characterized by my
personal experience which I freely admit.
But don't go work for
a company that you don't respect,
that you can't go home to your family and
tell them what they do, and
have them feel good about that.
It's not on the slide,
but don't go work for
a company if you won't relocate to
where the corporate headquarters is.
I can't tell you how many times
I've got this story, and it is so
obvious that I have to tell it.
I was interviewing a guy some years ago,
who was a extremely successful
Regional Manager for Medtronic.
Great company, wonderful company,
he was in Washington,
DC running the eastern region.
And they wanted him to
move to Minneapolis,
which is where the company
was headquartered.
And he didn't want to do that because
he want to stay in Washington,
and I asked him, I said,
how is this not predictable?
The only way that eventually you're not
going to get asked to go to the corporate
headquarters is if a, the company fails or
gets sold, or b, you're not very good.
And if you're not willing to
go where the seat of power is,
why in the world that you spend the last
ten years working your ass off to
generate this opportunity,
which now you're going to turn down?
Explain to me how that makes any sense?
So think about that.
Run something hard,
my biases if you've got an opportunity
to take a line job over a staff job,
do it, get P and
L responsibility, get hire and
fire responsibility.
Get something where you've got
budgets to run, people to hire,
things to manage that can be
measurable if you're successful.
And do the best to avoid things
that where your contribution isn't
measurable even if
the company is successful.
because you'll get some spin off from
being associated with a successful
company.
But it won't be as good as
if you can demonstrate that
something good happened because
you let it or you did it.
The people part,
sometimes people tend to think,
I don't think anybody
here would think that.
But sometimes people tend to think
that they don't want to hire really,
really good people because
it'll make them look bad or
they might overshadow them or
they might be risky to them.
And I'll tell you that's
a prescription I think, for
failure because two things,
you're not going to get promoted.
This is if you're in a corporate job in
a big company, but pretty much anywhere.
You're not going to get promoted to the
next big job unless whoever is going to
promote you thinks there's somebody
in your organization that can take
over for you.
And if you haven't got anybody, well,
you'll either sit in that job
until you do, or you'll get passed
over because you are perceived as
having good people working for you.
You work for great people,
they're going to get promoted,
they're going to pull you up behind them.
You hire really good people, they'll
push you up because they'll be ready for
new challenges.
You'll give it to them, that reflects
well on you, plus it makes you feel good.
And the last thing is,
there's nothing that I looked for.
And when I scan resumes, and
I talked to people about their background,
the first thing and the last thing, and
almost everything in-between that I
looked at was, where and
when did this person get promoted?
Because you get promoted when the people
or the company that you work for
thought you did a good enough job,
and what the job they gave you,
they give you a bigger one.
And it's amazing,
when I looked at careers,
we'd see backgrounds of somebody that
starts out, probably not a Stanford MBA,
but they start out as a District
sales manager of Company A.
And then a regional sales
leader of Company B, and
then a sales and
marketing director of company C.
And a VP of sales and
marketing company E and
the chief operating officer of company F.
Looks like a great progression of titles,
they never got promoted, never once.
So it makes you wonder,
were they just get out of town
just before the axe fell on them.
And getting lucky to use their background
to get promoted to another company that
would buy their story and
give them a bigger job.
When you look around, you'll see
people like this all the time, and
they're not the people
you want to go work for.
For one thing, they're going to be
splitting, they're not going to
take care of you because they're
only concerned about themselves.
And you don't want to be one of
those people, so think about.
If you're close, if you've got
an opportunity, or you're thinking about
leaving and you're close to finishing
a project you can take credit for, and
getting a promotion,
I would urge you think long and
hard before you leave anywhere
just short of a promotion.
Because somebody like
me is going to ask you,
why did you leave just shorter when you
should have probably gotten promoted?
Were are you going to get promoted?
Why didn't you get promoted?
Who got the job in that company
that you would have wanted?
Were they better than you?
So maybe I should be talking to them.
So a few final thoughts and
we'll go to Q&A.
The world is big, your world is bigger
than most people's worlds because you have
opportunities that most people don't have.
You've earned them by being here,
by having the capabilities to get here,
by making the sacrifice to come here.
And so your opportunity set is large.
Your networks, we talked on this, your
networks are much bigger than your biggest
imagination of how big they can be,
they're bigger if you think expansively.
People like to help.
As I said before, make it easy for
people to help you.
Don't make it hard, make it easy.
They'll do it,
they'll do it over and over again.
And be nice to them, somebody said, be
nice to the people you pass on your way up
the corporate ladder, you may pass
them again on your way down, but-
>> [LAUGH]
>> Hope not, but you'll see them again.
Success is measured in a lot of ways.
We can talk about being the CEO
of a Fortune 1000 company, and
maybe a couple of you in here will
do that, but most of you won't.
And that doesn't mean
you're less successful.
What matters is your success,
according to you, not according to me,
or your classmates, or
the school, or surveys.
What matters is your success according
to you, you measure it your way.
And don't let anybody convince you that
you should measure your success in life
any more than your happiness in
life by somebody else's standards.
They've got their own issues,
they've got their own goals.
You should have yours and
you should have every reason to
expect that you can achieve them.
Last comment is don't hit
the panic button too soon.
Life is long.
Enjoy the journey.
You've got a lot of great
experiences along the way.
There's a lot of people who will help
you and appreciate what you do, and
I can't, I wish I was out there.
And there's an Irish comedian
that used to say, gee,
I wish I was out there in
the audience listening to this.
But, in some ways,
I wish I was out there with
the opportunities that you all have
because they're really almost limitless.
And all I can say is I wish
you good luck with them and
we'll be tracking your progress.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Hopefully
there's something there that
gets some questions going, yeah.
>> Can you talk a little bit about the
process of getting wrapped up into a job
search with a recruiter, starting
with how you identify those four or
five out of the 500 that are relevant.
>> Yeah the question is, how do you
identify the recruiters who are right for
you to begin making
a relationship with over time.
There's two or three ways,
and I would try them all.
It starts by figuring out what
it is that you want to do.
And being as clear and
specific about that as you can, and
then you get to people
in the recruiting firms.
And there's five large ones, large,
large global ones, mine was one.
And then there's a dozen or so mid
tiered ones and then lots of small ones,
many of whom are founded and
staffed by alums of the big one.
So the quality is just as good,
they may be small.
You start asking people around
who does this kind of work and
you ask enough questions,
the same names will come up.
Second way to do it is reverse
engineer searches that got done.
If there's a job out there that
you would like to have had or
would like to have the next time,
and it just got filled.
You saw the announcement in the paper,
chances are there was a recruiter
that did that search.
Call up the company, call up
the individual in the job and say, look,
I see you got this promotion or
send him an email.
You can reach him on LinkedIn by the way.
We'll come back to that.
And say, I'm curious as to was there
a recruiter that handled this search and
if so, who was it and were they good?
Because if they were good for
them, they'll be good for you.
The one thing about the recruiting
profession is once you start building
the reputation for
doing certain kinds of searches.
The industry knows and they'll come back
to the same people time and time again for
those projects.
That's how they build specializations and
the same thing happens
within the search firms.
I got a lot of calls because I was
high profile from companies wanting
searches done.
Almost never would I do them.
So the question would be,
who would we recommend that they talk to?
And it's going to be the person in our
firm that has the best track record doing
those kinds of searches and
everybody knows who they are.
And so, at that point, your goal is
to figure out who those people are.
And try to get an opportunity
to have them know who you are.
And if they're willing to spend a little
bit of time, not a lot of time, but 15,
20 minutes meeting you, and just saying,
yeah, maybe I'm not a candidate for
anything right now, but I'm a candidate
for what you do as a recruiter.
And one of these days you're going to
have an assignment that I'm going to be
qualified for and interested in and
I wanted you to know who I was.
And that line of discussion
works if you're right,
if your facts are right, and
you've done your homework.
It's a waste of time if it's a random
blast at the recruiting world.
And just as it's pretty much a waste of
time to send resumes to recruiting firms,
don't bother, it's not worth the paper
you're printing your resumes on.
They get tens of thousands, most of
them unfortunately go in the scrap heap,
including some of the very same people
who come into them through their
sourcing exercises later on a search
that they pay a lot of attention to.
They wouldn't have paid any attention to
the resume coming in because they're not
geared to do the scan and match.
By the way, LinkedIn is an excellent way.
I mean, LinkedIn didn't exist for most
of my years in the recruiting business.
The search firms are using LinkedIn now,
massively.
And so you need to make sure
that your LinkedIn profile
is current and is as good as it can be.
And if you want to get to
somebody's recruiter or
somebody that you don't know, and you
don't know what their email address is.
If they have a LinkedIn account,
you can send them a LinkedIn mail on
the LinkedIn account and they'll get it.
It's the best way to reach somebody
that you don't know how to reach.
And so just sort of tuck that away,
you can do that I think on the basic
free LinkedIn subscription.
So many amounts of people here
probably know better than I.
But for a little bit of money,
you can move up to the higher levels for
even if it's just for a short period of
time while you're doing a job search and
you get a lot more access that way.
So, anyway, that's what I would do, yeah.
>> My question is, especially in
the valley, there's a bit of a blurred
line between what is a startup and
what is established company.
We've got companies growing into
hundreds of millions of dollars in like
a year or two.
>> Right.
>> And so, if I said,
well, there's a company to
raise series B financing.
It looks pretty solid.
So they raised say like north
of $20 million or $50 million.
Would you still say that you need
to have a seat at the table there?
>> Well, that's a mature startup.
That's not a pure startup from zero.
If they've done a series B and
they've got financing for
a year or more and
they're growing rapidly.
Then you might relax that because
they're going to be hiring
a lot of people that are not all
going to have a seat at the key table.
Then the question though To ask is, will
I have a seat at some interesting table?
And does the person that
I'm going to be working for
maybe have a seat at the big table?
I mean if you're working for
somebody and you won't have a seat at
an interesting table and you're
working for somebody that doesn't have
a seat at the big table but maybe has
heard about who the people are who do.
I'm not sure that's what you want to do.
But, if there's a path,
the company looks good,
that you're right it's in the fuzzy
area between a small and a big company.
I was more talking about a pure,
a seed round or a round startup,
which I think is much more risky
than what you just described.
Yeah, either one will get the other one.
>> For international people that we may
have some additional things like we don't
know the culture that much or we don't
know the network's industry that much.
We have maybe to figure out some
things related to the thesis.
What is can we highlight to set up with
maybe more simple local candidates?
>> Well, sure.
I think that almost everybody
has some kind of skills and
attributes that other people don't have.
And you're better off if
you can package those and
show them to somebody who
has an appreciation for him.
So I mean if you're not a US National and
you have extensive international
experience either in your home country or
in some third international country.
That's an asset that
companies are looking for
particularly companies who are going to
be expanding International.
I can help you go to Latin America, I can
help you go to Europe or Asia or India.
And so, the entry there may well be
through somebody in international.
One of the things a lot of people
find is an entry to the bigger
companies is through one
of their countrymen,
who's a prior graduate from here who,
would help them.
I mean, if you're Chilean,
you want to be making sure that
you're connected with the Chilean MBA
graduate community and
the Chilean community of
senior executives here.
And so it can vary because my
experience is in is they look out for
their country men, and
they'll try to find a way to help you.
And then that translates over to
introductions to other countries and
you move to Latin America, I'm just
used to using Chilean Latin Americans.
The example applies to
almost any anybody anywhere.
Okay, Lucky guests.
Great country by the way.
So, I think that's the case, don't,
again back to the open door and
the closed door, try to find some open
door where somebody wants to help you for
who you are, not wants to slam a door
in your face for who you're not.
And so I can't emphasize
that that's strong enough.
Find people that
are willing to help you and
let them get you through an open door and
then working around in the back as opposed
to trying to bang your way in through the
front where maybe they're not not so open.
Yeah, we missed you.
It's your turn.
[INAUDIBLE] While we can
use eight years not really,
that big a deal, it's accepted
if you fail as an entrepreneur.
I just want to try and build on that
sentiment because many of us here
come from non entrepreneurial background
and have come from corporates.
And have had reasonably
successful careers, but
are contemplating as
part of creature here.
The stint in entrepreneurship, there is
the risk that it could fail and search for
to get a sense for yourself is to that
point when you're trying to think through.
Okay, go back into corporate career.
Continue the momentum of taper extending.
Don't rush in and
take the potential risk or
the potential war not just compensation,
but also roll the seat you mentioned.
I'm trying to think how is really your
opinion, failure perceived because.
>> Yeah, it depends.
It's perceived differently,
depending on who's perceiving.
As I said, you graduate from here
you've got the opportunity to hit this
career reset button once.
But you don't get an unlimited number of
opportunities to hit that reset button.
You might get a second pop added in a
couple years if something didn't work out,
but then probably not.
The other comment I would make is
career transitions that I've watched
are historically quite easy from
large companies to small ones and
quite hard from small ones to large ones.
And so if you are going to go from
a big company background into
an odd entrepreneurial world
think long and hard about that
because it won't be that easy
to go back where you came from.
I mean, maybe if it's a year or
two, and you dumped back quick or
you go back to the company you work for
you might be able to do it.
But then I would almost say you weren't
really all that committed to going
into the startup world in the first
place if you were looking for
an opportunity to go back.
Like I said,
if it scares you to go big the failures,
Particularly in the entrepreneurial
community here,
are really almost no big deal.
But they tend to be perceived as a much
bigger deal by the bigger companies,
the bigger, more mature companies and
it's just a fact of life.
I think many of you have
probably experienced that.
So, I think the likelihood is if you
are committing to an entrepreneurial
career path,
that's a commitment you need to make.
And you need to probably believe
that it's a career long commitment
that's where you're going to
spend the rest of your career.
>> God forbid it did go well to
execute a search conference trying to
find the next job.
>> Well, they're not going to be
trying to find you the next job there.
They may be talking to you about
a position with one of their clients,
in which case they're
already interested in you.
So you don't have to
they found you somehow,
otherwise you didn't get in the door and
you weren't sitting in front of them.
So that's a positive interview, if you got
it, and then all you have to do I mean,
if it's a startup that failed,
yeah, it's a startup that failed.
This is what I thought
was going to happen.
The questions that I would ask would be
around the choices and the explanation for
the choice you made to go there, not so
much the outcome because
you can't control that.
What you can control is the choice
that you made to go there.
And so I really want to know, well,
why did you choose to go there?
What did you think the likely
outcome was going to be?
Why did you believe the company was
going to be successful turnout?
It wasn't, but those questions can have
very good and credible answers to them.
And that's what you should think about,
because as I said,
that's part of telling your story and
an answer.
They told me it was going to be great and
I didn't really check it or
one of my friends went there and
he said it was cool.
Or they had they had a cafeteria where
you could get food like all the time.
I mean, those are not very good,
I'm kidding you a little bit, but
those are not very good
answers to questions but
an honest assessment
that look I looked at it.
I thought the technology
was solid in place for
a year the execute team was
an equality team in my estimation.
And it didn't work out.
That is just fine.
At that point that's all I
want to know my next deal here.
And chances are you probably learned
something from that experience.
Which is also an important thing
to get into the discussion.
Who is next?
I think maybe you were.
>> Yeah, my question is can you
speak to the different types of
practices by Joker Began by industry?
So for example, the bay area seems to be
such firm diverse [INAUDIBLE] Network.
Whereas maybe other industries
have more blue chip,
senior that is much more
friendly towards search.
>> Sure.
Well, the first thing I think If
you're focused on particular company,
or particular set of companies,
figuring out what their hiring process is.
And who or what institutions
they use to help them in it,
is a good first step in it.
That's basic homework and
it shouldn't be very hard.
If you have questions,
you can call the HR department and talk to
somebody in their recruiting department.
Though, they'll tell you
the answers to those questions.
Do you use recruiters?
Is a no, if you do use recruiters,
who do you use?
What do you use them for?
What level?
I think you're correct.
There's a huge infrastructure, have
talent moving around in Silicon Valley.
It's almost unique in the world.
And it's not that they don't use
recruiters, they use everything.
And they use everything in volume.
I mean, the recruiting business here is
very strong, but so is direct recruiting.
I mean, most of the major companies have
created big in house recruiting staffs.
Most of those staffs worked at one point
or other in their big search firms.
I mean, top recruiters at Apple pretty
much all work for me over the years.
And in other places though, where the
local talent pool is maybe not quite so
vibrant, companies will tend
to rely on recruiters more.
And that tends to be the case as you
go up more and more senior levels.
At the officer level,
I just did chief CXO searches and
CEO searches for
medium to big companies for the most part.
Pretty much all those searches still
use recruiters, executive recruiters.
But levels below that is a complete
mixed bag, and a lot of its networking.
And so here's where your networks really
matter a lot, is to tap on both for
contacts.
And to tap in for information in terms
of how this particular company hires.
And if you want to get in the hiring
process and cycle for this company,
or this set of companies.
How do you do that?
And people will tell you, this is
where graduates of this program two,
three years out working in these companies
who sat in these chairs two years ago.
And are out doing those jobs now
are the people I'd be talking to,
not me I'm too far removed from that.
But I know there are a lot of people
out there, who are willing to help you.
And they're pretty easily identified,
Virginia can tell you who they all are.
She knows them all.
Mike they know more.
I think you were next?
>> [INAUDIBLE] While the recommendations
you have how we ourselves [INAUDIBLE]
>> Okay, question is about sourcing.
Recruiters when they do searches,
use a variety of techniques.
One, they all have databases of
candidates that they maintain, not not so
much from resumes sent to them.
But by profiles they've created over
the years candidates they've interviewed.
Maybe presented and
want to do present again because
that's they've got qualified people.
So they look at that,
that's all categorized,
they look at their own prior
search work that similar.
Where do we do a search like this,
the last time?
And who were the candidates who came in
second, third, fourth on that search,
that maybe would be a good fit for this.
They do industry sourcing which is what
you talked about where they call around
typically at a level or two above.
What they're trying to find.
If I'm doing a search for
a marketing, VP, I'm calling CEOs,
and saying,
who are the best marketing people,
you know in your competitors,
maybe not one of your people?
Sometimes they'll even suggest one
of their people that is blocked.
Surprisingly it happens.
Who's worked for you over the years
that you think is really good.
And here, this is where if you've
worked for really strong mentors and
strong performers, they know about you,
If you stay in touch with them as even if
they've moved on from where you are,
they'll think about you.
They'll recommend you.
because they're the people with
the reputations who are going to get
the calls.
The weak ones don't get those calls,
the strong ones get those calls.
And are in a position to help influence
the hiring of people that either they
know about, or
more likely have worked for them, or for
their other teams over the years.
And really good executives, I find tend to
take very good care of people who perform
for them over the years.
I mean, they'll recommend them for jobs,
they'll proactively recommend them for
jobs.
And in fact, if you've got
a good relationship with them,
you can go ask them to do that.
Go to somebody who is a boss
of yours in another company.
If that was a good relationship,
he or she has a good feeling for you,
call them and say, look,
I'm ready to make a move.
Who should I be talking to?
Who in this search firm world, do you know
that you'd be willing to introduce me to,
and if somebody reaches out to you,
well, keep me in mind.
So, Okay
>> How do I translate?
>> Well, two things.
One, if they're international firms,
that have offices in the UK, and you have
good relationships with the recruiters
in the UK, ask them if they'd be willing
to introduce you to their counterparts
here in Silicon valley in their firms.
Most of them will be willing to do
that if the firms are large and
have offices in both places.
If not, then the other source is,
it could be the UK expat community here,
people who are Brits
are working in Silicon Valley.
There's lots of them.
And my experience has been.
As I said before,
they're willing to help their countrymen,
because they know you're in a strange
land here and you need a little help.
So those would probably be my
two first places that I would go
beyond just the normal networking
that I talked about before.
I will take you, and then you, yeah.
>> I'm a little bit reticent
to ask a question up here.
So I'm afraid that you can read minds.
>> [LAUGH].
>> Anyway, so let me
>> have a good day sometimes.
So on the topic of magical powers, if you
could look into the future, say 20 or
30 years ahead, hypothetically, a lot of
CEOs previously came from operations and
then sales and then the finance.
Will there be a chain,
the origin of where CEOs come from
particularly if they've got a technology
background are technologists.
And we got to be getting that we got to
have the case to the executive washroom.
>> Well, some do, and some have I think
Technologists are going to continue
to run technology companies.
And if you look at even
the near term future,
most of the important companies
are going to be technology companies,
or are going to be trying to
claim to the world that they're
technology companies even
if they're really not.
I don't know if you saw the cover
article in Fortune this weekend,
a picture of Bob Iger of Disney on the
cover talking about Disney as a technology
company and his efforts to remake
Disney as a technology company.
So Bob had no technology in his
background and he's now a technical guru.
I still think as I mentioned before,
that the people that are going to
move up are the ones that have
taken responsibilities for
pieces of business and
have run them successfully.
And you can get a business unit in
a larger company or even a smaller
company to run if you set out to do
that pretty early in your career.
It might not be a massive one but
if you take a small one and
turn it into a medium sized one, that's
going to be, that's a pretty good record.
Then the next time around,
they give you a medium sized one,
you turn it into a big one, you're
successful at that, you can do anything.
And so I actually think the question,
I'd almost come back at that question and
reverse it.
And it's not so
much what functional areas they're
going to be looking to for
their next leaders.
They're going to look for leaders.
And they're going to take them
from wherever they can find them,
whatever they've been doing,
if they think they have the leadership
capabilities to run their company or
if we think they have the leadership
capabilities to run another company.
But you gotta be in a position to have
shown your leadership capabilities
before somebody can look at you and
say, this is a leader who we can give
a bigger job to and if it's been
all staff, that's really hard.
Some combination of line and staff if
you've got credible line experience and
some great executives have gone back and
forth between line and staff.
And there's a few that have gotten
to the top of big companies,
all staff through consulting or,
Staff jobs,
typically more finance than say the softer
ones like planning or HR or PR.
But I still think that setting
out to build a record of
having been successful running something
where that success can be measured.
And people recognize it is the best
path that I can find to leadership.
There's a question I wasn't asked yet,
at least today but I'm going to ask it and
then answer it because it gets back to
setting the reset button in your career.
And some of you here may want to go and
make a radical shift.
I don't know that to be true,
but there's always some and
if you've been doing consumer products and
you want to go to tech,
or even all big company and
you want to go to startup.
And people ask me about, How that kind of
a desire matches up with
executive recruiters.
And the answer is, it doesn't.
Hardly at all.
And you will frustrate
yourself a lot if in fact
you're trying to make that work because 99
times out of 100 it isn't going to work.
What recruiters want, they want an easy
path to a solution of a client problem.
And they've got a defined spec.
And let's call it a marketing director
position for PC apps business.
Well who are they going to present
as candidates on that search?
They're going to present probably
three candidates after a work.
They want to present the top individual
in that job for their client company's
biggest competitor, or the number two
person in a company a lot bigger.
Or somebody two levels
up In a smaller company
in the same space or
a closely related space.
So, basically somebody that's
done this job before and
can come in here and
do this job for my client fast.
They're not going to present
somebody who was a finance manager
in a consumer project products
company that got his MBA and
now wants to be a marketing
manager in tech.
It's not going to happen,
that job can happen but
not down that channel.
If you want to make a jump shift,
what is what we call a jump shift,
change of function and change of industry.
You're likely not going to get much
help from the executive recruiting
profession to do that.
And that's just a fact.
And I just want to tell
you that clear because
don't waste your time trying to convince
them to do that because they're not.
You gotta go find that another way.
And the way you find it is typically by
somebody who knows you, that's seen you
work somewhere else before and is in a
position to say, yeah, I know you've never
done that before but I know you can do
it because I've seen what you can do.
That's not how that get, that doesn't get
done through a third party recruiter,
but it gets done every day through
your personal networks and
your personal contacts.
So, if that's what you want to do,
then that's what you gotta work.
If you know what you want to do and
you've done it and
you've got demonstrable
record of doing it,
then there are recruiters out there
that are going to jump all over you and
try to get you your next job in that
field, either a jump or a shift.
See, by a jump, higher level job,
doing the same thing up from director
to VP, same industry, same function.
Shift, same function, different industry,
Director of Marketing from
consumer products to tech.
Yeah, probably if there's some
credible way you can do it.
So I call that a jump or a shift.
But if you try to do what in basketball or
some they call the jump shift,
which is change of level and
change of industry and function,
change your function and
change your industry, very very hard.
And you gotta go work that on your own.
Yes, thank you.
>> That was my question but
I have another one.
Have you also to recruiters and to future
employees promote the year that you
took here,
because I've got mixed feedback and
then were like,
why have you already had a great career?
Why would you break that?
And go and take an exam,
like a one year program and send forth.
What is your best answer
to that apart from
obviously the personal
>> What's your best
answer to that question?
>> That I wanted to,
I have the headquarter, sorry,
I didn't want to stay with my headquarter.
So I wanted to have a career break.
I wanted to switch not my function but
unfortunately my company because I didn't
want to be with their headquarters.
>> Okay.
>> And I wanted to use that time To really
get some educational aspects and
a new perspective.
>> Okay, I'd say that, sorry, it's fair.
I think you can improve that.
And I think you would improve
it by being more positive
about the opportunity that
you want to go to and
less negative about the one
that you were leaving,
because nobody really wants to hear that.
I mean, for example, you had learned all
that you could learn, you knew you were
missing some skills to move up to
the next critical level in management and
you thought this was the most time
efficient way that you could add those
skills and at the same time enhance
your career and move to a bigger job in
a different company because you didn't
see that opportunity where you were.
To me that's a much more positive story,
some version of that.
Again, I think nobody's
going to believe the story
that you tell them unless you believe it.
So, first off, you have to believe it,
you have to be convincing in telling it,
but to the extent that it can be much
more positive and less negative.
This is your elevator pitch and
sort of like what you'd tell
somebody if they say you got two
minutes to tell me why I should
give you another ten minutes.
You want to have a really good story
that you can tell when you do that,.
And I would just say,
don't be defensive, no reason to.
There's not a reason in the world for
any of you to be defensive coming here.
You've made a big
investment of your life and
your time to improve your
skills dramatically, I believe.
And I think most people would assume that.
There are some MBA haters in the world,
some of them are vocal,
some of them are active in
the venture capital community.
Some of them have gone out of their way
to say that an MBA is a complete waste of
time and money.
In fact, a college education is
a complete waste of time and money,
you should just go code.
Well, easy for
them to say because you're billionaires.
But you probably you're not going to get
very far convincing one of those people
that your time here was well spent.
So I go back to the Jim Collins
analogy of the open door,
forget about those people and go spend
your time with people who appreciate what
you did here, and there's lots of people.
And you don't even have to take an
editorial position about who's right and
who's wrong.
But I can tell you clearly one of them is
a much more likely opportunity set for
you than the other one without whether
you agree with their premise or not.
If they think this is a waste of
time they're not going to help you,
go somewhere else.
Yeah, okay.
>> I'm curious about what we'd like to
say about compensation to get some words.
>> About compensation?
Let me see if I can boil it down
into a couple of key points.
One is, ask a lot of questions.
Because the more information you have,
the more power that you will have.
Compensation has a lot more elements to
it typically than most people identify.
At senior levels, a compensation package
is going to have maybe as many as eight or
ten major components.
We tend to think about base salary,
cash incentive bonus and
equity grants, kind of the big three, but
there's relocation allowances,
home buying programs,
pension gross-ups, signing bonuses,
special project-based incentive
incentive options and
as many things as people can dream up.
So the first thing you want to do when
you're in a compensation discussion with
anybody is find out how many of those
elements might possibly come into play.
Do you have project-based bonuses?
Do you use signing bonuses?
How do you reward option
grants if I'm relocating?
How do you deal with relocation?
Is a home buyout part of that blah,
blah, blah?
And so now you've got
a framework of what's possible.
And there might be something on
that list that could be really,
really valuable to you.
If you're going to work for Stanford,
your kids get to get to go to Stanford.
I mean, if you get college age kids,
I mean,
I know people who have stayed here
because of that, that's huge.
And so find out what the list is.
And then the other thing I tell people,
a compensation discussion is a little
bit like working at a mixing
board in a sound studio.
You ever see these things, they got all
these, they're trying to manage the sound.
Probably there's a guy back there
behind the wall doing that right now.
And you got about ten levers that,
various levels of the sound,
you can't push them all to maximum
because you just get garbage.
It's the same thing in
a compensation discussion.
You can't push everything to maximum but
you can probably push something.
And one of the things that I tell people,
try to find the soft
money if there is any.
I mean, maybe the individual you're
talking to has a severe salary cap and
they just can't go any higher but
they've got a lot of
discretion on a signing bonus.
Well, money's money, okay?
So you don't get, and so
maybe you don't get that extra 25 or
$50,000 in salary but
you pick up $100,000 signing bonus.
Well, that's pretty good because you're
going to have a salary negotiation
again in a year but maybe you can
negotiate it to six months and
get a review in six months.
Again, what's the review cycle?
That's one of the items on the list
oeople don't tend to think about.
So, recognize at the end
of the day that if you
push too many of the levers
you could blow the deal.
But you can push some and
people expect you to push some.
They're I think particularly
impressed if you do it intelligently,
particularly if you push something
that's not one of the top three.
And if you've done your homework,
first off, I mean at a minimum,
if you're replacing somebody,
you should be able to get everything that
that individual got because that's
already been approved in the system.
So that's a starting point.
And usually if you ask,
you can find out what that is.
If you know what industry counterparts
that their competitors get for
the same job, that's useful information.
And so, again, do your homework,
figure out what the elements are,
push the one that in particular
is worth more to you to get than
it is to them to give it to you.
And that's where you can really, if you
push on something where they're resisting,
that's going to be hard.
So go find somewhere else to.
So it's another version of an open door
[LAUGH] but it's go find something
that's easy as opposed to fighting
over something that's hard.
And, I mean, at the end of the day,
I always try to encourage people
in that negotiation to try to
get the company to accept that you
want to bet on your own performance.
So go for bigger upside on bonuses,
shorter reviews, project bonuses.
Okay, I'll go in at this level,
it's a little less than what
I want in terms of salary.
But given that, is it possible that
I can have a review of six months and
if the performance warrants
I get that adjustment?
That's pretty soft.
They're not given much.
They're not giving away any money.
They may well agree to that.
And if you perform,
then you get it in six months.
If you don't perform,
you weren't going to get it anyway.
[MUSIC]